[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت لولوا الخاطر
مساعده وزير الخارجيه القطري في مؤتمر
صحفي بالدوحه قالت ان دوله قطر ومن خلال
مبادره فيفا قطر 2022 للجميع اقامت مناطق
مشجعين خاصه للنجاحين واللاجئين في عدد من
الدول منها فلسطين والاردن والعراق واليمن
والسدا
كده دوله قطر
الشعوب وتعزيز السلامه والحوار والمصالحه
ان حرصنا على اقامه مناطق المشجعين
يترجموا ايماننا راسخ بقدره الرياضه على
احداث تغيير اجتماعيا ايجابي يحفزوا
التنميه المستدامه لا سيما من خلال تشجيع
التسامح والاحترام وتمكين المجتمعات
واكدت مساعده وزير الخارجيه القطريه على
ان قطر تضع الوساطه والدبلوماسيه الوقائيه
في صداره اولويات سياستها الخارجيه
اننا نشاطر
ومعاناتهم اليوميه ونجدد التاكيد على ان
دوله قطر تضع الوساطه والدبلوماسيه
الوقائيه في صداره اولوياته سياستها
الخارجيه وهي تعمل بجد مع الشركاء في جميع
انحاء العالم لتحقيق الامن والسلامه
والضمان مستقبل افضل للبشريه جمعه
املينا ان تمثل مناطق المشجعين لاشقائنا
اللاجئين والنازحين بارقه امل ولحظه
يختطفونها من عمر الزمن يشاركونا ونشاركهم
فرحه مونديال العرب قطر 20 22